Red-hot lava is still shooting into the air
from a volcano on the Spanish island of La
Palma.
During a visit to the island, Spanish Prime
Minister Pedro Sanchez pledged government
aid to rebuild, even as there's no sign of
the eruption diminishing.
La Palma's volcano won't let up.
It's been spewing molten rock into the air
for weeks.
In the smoldering light of day, you can barely
see through the smoke and the burning ash.
The volcano has burst back into life after
50 years, and some of the residents are trying
their best to take it all in their stride.
"A lot of people lost everything and this
is a demon for them.
I see things a bit more rationally here.
I can't change it but I have to keep going
with the things I still have, we have to keep
living."
The Cumbre Vieja volcano has already destroyed
almost a thousand buildings, and the lava
continues to threaten nearby communities.
Spain's government has offered support, and
is set to approve more than 200 million euros
in aid this week.
"We do not know when the volcanic eruption
will end, but what the people of La Palma
should know is that, regardless of when this
ends, the Spanish government, all the institutions,
will be there to face the enormous task of
rebuilding La Palma and to offer a horizon
of prosperity, progress and tranquility to
the people of La Palma."
The island's residents have already received
some emergency funds: immediate assistance
for those who have lost their homes.
But, this is an island that relies heavily
on tourism.
Something the local government has been keen
to emphasize.
"I would like to say at this point that the
best way to help La Palma is to treat us normally,
to visit us, to help us to stimulate the economy,
that our hotels are in business, that the
restaurants and cafes are open, that taxi
drivers, farmers and traders, all of us can
all reactivate the economy."
The explosive activity in the vents of the
volcano intensified on Sunday, causing several
minor earthquakes nearby.
So far, no casualties have been reported – thanks,
mainly, to speedy evacuation efforts.